na dann herzlich willkommen zum
pressebriefing im robert-koch-institut
am 20 märz heute wieder mit lothar
wieler dem präsidenten des robert koch
instituts und wie immer wird einen
kurzen überblick geben über die aktuelle
situation
danach haben sie die gelegenheit fragen
zu stellen und schon mal als ankündigung
herr wiener muss um zehn und dreißig
spätestens los das heißt wir müssen uns
heute ein bisschen begrenzen und meine
bitte an alle halten sie etwas mehr
abstand voneinander also gerade sie oben
vielleicht auch die kamerateams
irgendwie geht dass er lieb vielen dank
guten morgen zusammen hier im hörsaal
guten morgen auch an den die zuhörer und
zuschauer von außerhalb von china
begrüße auch sie herzlich schön dass sie
heute wieder übersetzen nun wie immer
zunächst ein paar nüchterne zahlen bei
allem zahlen die wir ihnen verkünden
müssen sie immer wissen was ich auch
immer wieder betonen dass das natürlich
die offiziell gemeldeten zahlen sind und
dass natürlich die zahl der waren fälle
immer höher liegen wird denn wir können
ja nur dass ihnen mitteilen was
offiziell gemeldet wird und das ist
wichtig um lagen zu analysieren um
daraus analysen und und rückschlüsse zu
ziehen
zunächst ein blick auf die welt und zwar
ist das der stand vom 19 dritten von
acht uhr das sind daten die vom
europäischen center for disease control
übermittelt werden und wie wir das schon
länger angekündigt haben werden wir
jetzt bestimmte zahlen einmal am tag
updaten damit die unterschiedlichen
zahlen auch jedem klar werden wir
beziehen uns international ist noch
ausschließlich auf die informationen vom
european centre for disease control
gestern morgen 8 uhr weltweit über
200.000 fälle gemeldet
also das sind die registrierten fälle
das ist im gegensatz zum vortag sind das
17.000 melle fälle mehr
das ist also eine sehr sehr
marke zunahmen darunter befinden sich
offiziell gemeldet 8830 verstorbene in
china sind die fälle 81 1238 gestern um
8 uhr morgens das sind 75 mehr als am
vortag
in den ländern außerhalb von chinas also
deutlich höhere zahlen offiziell
gemeldet 124.000 annähernd das ist die
differenz zum vortag 17.200 28 wir haben
hier insgesamt 5580 todesfälle offiziell
gemeldet bekommen in der whu region euro
ist das intensivste geschehen in dieser
pandemie 79.000 229 fälle sind elf 1510
mehr als am 18
38 jetzt ein paar zahlen von einigen
ländern um ihnen die unterschiedliche
dynamik noch mal klar zu machen ich
möchte ihnen auch mal sagen dass wir in
deutschland zeit gewonnen haben um
unsere krankenhäuser vorzubereiten und
ich seit wochen appelliere an die
krankenhäuser vorbereitet zu sein und an
die ärzteschaft aber wir stehen eben vor
einer ähnlichen entwicklung
das sage ich auch seit vielen wochen und
ich möchte sie dass sie das den ernst
der lage auch alle begreifen
in italien haben wir gestern um 8 uhr
morgens 35.700 fälle und das sind
insgesamt mehr 4207 fälle mehr als am 18
38 uhr spanien 13.700 16 fälle 2538 mehr
als am vortag
die vereinigten staaten haben wir eine
offizielle meldezahl von 9015 das sind
fast 3000 mehr als am vortag also sie
sehen dass diese pandemie weiter läuft
und es wird in allen ländern zur
erhöhung der zahlen in den nächsten
wochen kommen
es ist eine dynamische entwicklung und
sie zeigt eben leider in fast allen
ländern nach oben so wie das auch in
deutschland der fall ist
und jetzt kommen wir zu deutschland die
situation ein wenig genauer in den blick
genommen die zahlen die ihn jetzt von
der melde- sind die wir angekündigt
haben
das sind immer die zahlen von null uhr
also von 20 30 uhr
in deutschland wurden bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt rund 14.000 fälle elektronisch
übermitteln 13 1957 ganz genau und das
sind gegenüber dem vortag mit 2009 158
fälle mehr
ich sagte dass bereits wir sind in einem
exponentiellen wachstum bei uns wohnen
insgesamt 31 todesfälle übermittelt
bislang sind elf mehr als am vortag
also bei uns wurden 2009 158
übermittelte fälle mehr als am vortag
und insgesamt haben wir 31 todesfälle
bis heute 0 uhr übermittelt bekommen und
das sind 11 mehr als es am vortag uns
übermittelt wurden ein wenig genauer
hineingeschaut in die zahlen die uns
offiziell übermittelt worden
wir haben in deutschland eine gesamt
incident sind zwischen schon von 17
fällen pro 100.000 ich sage es nochmal
das ist ein exponentielles wachstum aber
diese evident diese inzidenz variiert
deutschlandweit stark auch das betone
ich immer wieder das ist ein grund warum
man in verschiedenen regionen auch
unterschiedlich starke maßnahmen fahren
kann angepasst in analysen
wir müssen immer mit kühlem kopf alle
uns zur verfügung stehenden daten
analysieren und entsprechend handeln in
hamburg zum beispiel haben wir 32 fälle
pro 100.000 einwohner in thüringen
sieben fälle pro 100.000 einwohner
was sind die symptome der fälle in
deutschland
21.30 uhr wir wissen von 9000 fällen
rund welche klinischen informationen
vorliegen
sehr viele haben husten mehr als die
hälfte habe husten trockener husten ist
ein typisches symptom was wir immer mehr
lernen und was ich immer mehr bestätigt
fieber haben 40 prozent der gemeldeten
fälle also jeder fürchte vier von zehn
hat diese diese symptome in deutschland
differieren die zahlen von bundesland zu
bundesland sehr stark war dem
württemberg hatten wir um 0 uhr 2007 146
fälle in bayern
2401 in nordrhein-westfalen 3497 in
anderen bundesländern kann das ganz
anders aussehen thüringen 149 und
mecklenburg vorpommern 101 und reist
also unterschiedliche zahlen wie bei
jeder epidemie verlaufen diese epidemien
regional unterschiedlich und das ist
auch wichtig zu verstehen so dass auch
die maßnahmen die die landräte und
landrätinnen und die oberbürgermeisterin
und oberbürgermeister die dafür
verantwortlich sind wie vor ort reagiert
wird was sie auch dazu veranlassen kann
unterschiedlich graduierte maßnahmen
anzuordnen
meine damen und herren wir sind
natürlich inzwischen auch in der
überlegung ob es zukunft noch so sein
wird dass wir risikogebiete auswerten
das werden wir schauen wir haben immer
davon gesprochen dass sich in einer so
dynamischen lage unsere kriterien
ständig überdacht werden angepasst
werden wir werden das sehen wie wir
damit weiter umgehen
es kann sein das ist in manchen regionen
nicht mehr sinnvoll ist es getrennt zu
betrachten
für uns sind die risikogebiete immer
definiert worden um ärzten eine
handlungsanweisung zudem eine empfehlung
zu geben warum sie eine person testen
müssen
oder nicht es sind epidemiologische mark
systematisch marca systematisch
indikatoren für ärzte und ärztinnen um
personen zu testen oder nicht
und zu wissen ob personen zu bestimmten
risikogebieten gehören wir schauen wenn
demnächst überall risikogebiete sind ob
wir das noch weiter tragen können ein
paar informationen noch weiter ich hatte
ein dashboard angekündigt sodass viele
genauere informationen haben können über
die dynamik bilder sind sehr wichtig
vermittler unter anderem ihr das
geschehen sehr viel leichter als zahlen
ich glaube das geht den meisten menschen
so dass der sport ist jetzt online
geschaltet ab 8 uhr heute morgen dort
können sie auf landkreisebene sehen die
anzahl der fälle das sind gute grafiken
verständlichen grafiken wir arbeiten da
zusammen mit der firma es wie in
deutschland
und auch andere ressort
forschungsinstitute unterstützen sie
großartig mit kartenmaterial es wird
also kontinuierlich
auch das wird kontinuierlich weiter
bearbeitet auch hier sind wir natürlich
in einem dynamischen prozess und wir tun
soviel wie möglich um unsere bevölkerung
so gut wie möglich so transparent wie
möglich zu informieren das ist ganz
wichtig dass jeder weiß was geschieht in
unserem land da käme auch neue
informationen dazu zum beispiel die zahl
der neuinfektionen pro tag oder der
anstieg der fallzahlen über einen
bestimmten zeitraum
wir werden also dieses tool immer
weiterentwickeln um allen die
gelegenheit zu geben einblicke zu haben
wenn das was in unserem land geschieht
das wird täglich zu einem
situationsbericht ergänzend seien auch
hier nochmal der hinweis dass das
dashboard auf offiziellen welle daten
beruht also den fällen die von den
gesundheitsämtern elektronisch an das
rki übermittelt werden
wir werden versuchen dieses dashboard
jeden tag um 0 uhr abzudecken genauso zu
der zeit wo wir die zahlen die ich ihnen
verkünde morgens oder ein kollege
professor schade
das nämlich zum schluss noch mal ein
appell richten an alle und ich sage das
noch mal ganz ganz ernsthaft bewusst mit
aller entschiedenheit
wir können diese epidemie nur
verlangsamt wenn wir uns an die
spielregeln halten distanzierung abstand
halten
das virus wird in erster linie von
mensch zu mensch übertragen jeder muss
verstehen dass er mindestens ein meter
fünfzig zwei meter abstand halten soll
damit er keinen anderen ansteckt
wer krank ist bleibe bitte zu hause und
wenn er zu hause bleibt bleibe er bitte
auch so weit wie möglich distanziert er
sich eben von seinem mit
familienmitgliedern um sie nicht
anzustecken
das virus wird von mensch zu mensch
übertragen wir alle können die
übertragung dadurch verlangsamen oder
einstellen
das heißt bitte halten sie abstand und
wenn es menschen gibt die auf ein test
warten und das ergebnis vielleicht nicht
umgehend bekommen bitte nehmen sie sich
in selbst kannte bleiben sie bitte zu
hause
das muss jeder verstehen und ich
wiederhole auch noch mal ein appell auch
das sagen wir seit anfang dieser
epidemie
jeder kann von diesem virus infiziert
werden unabhängig von der altersgruppe
aber das risiko schwer zu erkranken und
verstärkt zu versterben steigt mit dem
alter und den grundkrankheiten das heißt
auch wenn junge menschen nur leichte
symptome haben können sie aber trotzdem
alte menschen anstecken und dann dazu
beitragen dass die alten menschen sich
infizieren
bitte nehmen sie rücksicht wir alle
können eben auch andere schützen
und ich denke das wollen wir auch alle
mit allen menschen mit denen ich bisher
gesprochen habe alle die verstanden
haben was diese epidemie für unser land
bedeutet
die verstehen das und ich sehe
unheimlich viele gute auswirkungen ganz
viele beispiele wo menschen das
verstehen und ich bitte sie hier eben
auch im hörsaal diese distanzen zu
wahren und wir überlegen uns wie wir das
hier auch demnächst noch anders
regulieren wir werden sie in opfer das
sind der fall war
in der art und weise wie wir das
pressebriefing machen dass in der
zukunft noch machen
es gibt eine untersuchung von bitkom
einem digital verband eine
repräsentative umfrage und der zufolge
sind viele menschen hierzulande immer
noch nicht bereit ihre sozialen kontakte
zu reduzieren trotz aller appelle von
mir von vielen anderen leuten die
verantwortungsbewusst den deal
sicherheit und die gesundheit unserer
mitmenschen wirklich ein großes anliegen
ist nur jeder zweite der befragten geht
kommen auf die straße da trifft sich
seltener mit freunden und familie
jeder vierte meint das alles für
panikmache
ich habe diesen job hier angetreten weil
ich gesagt habe unser robert koch
institut möchte bürger schützen möchte
die gesundheit der bürger verbessern
möchte dazu beitragen wissenschaftlich
fundierte ergebnisse in die bürger
einbringen in alle menschen in
deutschland leben und das ist mein
auftrag das ist er seit nunmehr fünf
jahren und 20 tagen und allem robert
koch-institut tun das ihrige dazu um wie
diesen dieser arbeit zu erleichtern
die informationen die ich ihnen
vermitteln sind nicht meine information
eines experten der sich täglich
weiterbildet und beliebt sondern sind
die informationen die mir ein team von
mehreren hundert kolleginnen und
kollegen aus dem institut gibt
informationen die wir erhalten von
befreundeten wissenschaftlern
wissenschaftlerinnen aus anderen
instituten wie wir sie sind es gibt fast
jedem land institute wie das
robert-koch-institut mit verschiedenen
ausrichten sind informationen die wir
erhalten in beratungen mit gruppen der
whu ich selber bin mitglied einer
beratergruppe der wow beraten direkt
mike ryan den chef des world images i
programms ein mann den ich bereits will
ich schon bereits mehrfach gesagt
aber extrem bewundere der seit
jahrzehnten sich mit allen krisen
rumschlägt erfahrene leute ich sage
ihnen das weil ich überzeugt bin davon
das ist richtig ist und im nachhinein
werdet auch das ein oder andere
vielleicht hätte man lieber anders
gesagt oder früher oder später
wir alle sind in einer krise die ein
ausmass hat dass ich mir selber nie
hätte vorstellen können und wir tun alle
so gut wie möglich dass wir diese krise
so gut wie möglich meistern
darum noch mal zum schluss wir brauchen
in den hospitälern so viel wie möglich
beatmungs betten wir brauchen so viel
wie möglich intensivbetten ich
appelliere seit wochen an die
krankenhäuser sich darauf vorzubereiten
auf diese krise aber jetzt muss es so
weit sein
ja ich erwarte jetzt dass die
krankenhäuser vorbereitet sind
denn die die fälle werden zunehmen und
ich sage es auch nochmal ganz viele
menschen werden diese krankheit ganz
easy überstehen
wir haben jetzt schon sicher mehr als
1000 menschen die die krankheit
überstanden von denen wir wissen es
werden wahrscheinlich mehr sein aber es
wird eben auch sehr viele sehr shorten
schwer erkranken und die müssen wir
schützen
um die geht es dass wir sie medizinisch
noch adäquat versorgen können darum
bitte halten sie abstand wenn sie krank
sind bleiben sie zu hause
stecken sie niemanden an halten sie
abstand und dann werden wir das so gut
wie möglich hinbekommen dass wir so
viele wie möglich unserer mitmenschen
die in unserem land leben
medizinisch gut betreuen könnten danke
sehr ihre fragen so viele gleichzeitig
also die antwort ist die die ich schon
lange gebe und die korrekt ist wir
stehen am anfang einer epidemie wenn
eine epidemie sehe ich als eine kurve
vorstellen da sind wir links unten noch
wäre rutschen aber immer weiter nach
oben
ja wir haben es früh erkannt weil wir
früh getestet haben und wir werden
leider in zukunft mehr fälle bei uns
gilt als kronach todesfall jemand der
bei dem eine corona virus infektion
nachgewiesen wurde
das kann ich nicht so detailliert
beantworten aber von dem was wir sehen
denken wir dass die jüngeren sich am
unvernünftig sind verhalten also eben
immer noch zu stark zusammen kommen wir
haben aber nicht genügend daten wir
finden die mehrheit der infizierten die
getestet werden sind mit leute in der
mittelalten gruppe zwischen 30 und 50
wir können das noch nicht so detailliert
sagen aber ich will nur noch mal sagen
jeder muss sich distanzieren muss
möglichst sich von anderen verein halten
um keine anderen anzustehen
meine rolle ist die eines
wissenschaftlers eines unabhängigen
wissenschaftler dass diese institute hat
ja mehrere vorteile wir sie stehen nicht
in einem wettbewerb wie das vielleicht
andere wissenschaftler tun um bestimmte
drittmittel und bestimmte incentives wir
stehen nicht in einem wettbewerb mit
kommerziellen anbietern wir sind
unabhängig das ist die große stärke und
das ist der grund warum so einen laden
wir unsere überhaupt gibt also schulden
sie das also ein institut wie unseres
überhaupt gibt das heißt wir können
nichts weiter tun als die fakten und die
annahmen die wir berechnen zu vermitteln
was wir empfehlen habe ich gesagt
maximale distanzierung abstand halten
die maßnahmen die sich daraus ergeben
müssen die verantwortungsträger
natürlich ableiten wir empfehlen wir
sind wissenschaftler
das ist unser job und auf den
empfehlungen die wir von unserem
wissenschaftlichen knowhow hergeben
müssen maßnahmen von den
entscheidungsträgern umgesetzt wird das
ist nicht unser job
also die die zahlen steigen eigentlich
immer weiter die test kapazitäten werden
immer weiter hochgefahren
ich kann ihnen die die den umfang nicht
genau nennen aber es werden im prinzip
immer mehr
das war sie ihn sagt 160.000 waren die
durchgeführten tests ja klar gibt es
schutz angaben ich meine es gibt die
klaren empfehlungen
die gab es ja auch schon vor der korona
krise das gruner virus ist ein virus das
über tröpfchen übertragen wird
und dafür gibt es ganz normale
anweisungen wie man sich schützt im
krankenhaus ja da gibt es empfehlungen
von der kranken und von verschiedenen
gruppierungen die sind die die haben
sich nicht verändert
all das für alle also für alle diese
bereiche wo sind die versorgung von
medien von patienten gibt und auch in
alten pflegen diese in altenheim gibt es
empfehlungen von uns selbstverständlich
und die sind klar
das sind nämlich das tragen von
schutzkleidung und schutzmasken und mund
nasen schutz
also warum die menschen vor grippe nicht
so viel sorge haben wie sie haben
sollten ist mini eingängig gewesen ich
bitte sie alle die die wir berichten
auch klar zu machen dass crippen eine
schwerwiegende krankheit ist aber
unabhängig davon
diese krankheit überträgt sich sehr
effizient ja leichter das heißt also die
übertragung von einem menschen zum
anderen ist gelingt leichter als bei der
grippe der anteil der menschen die
schwer erkranken ist deutlich höher der
anteil der menschen in den risikogruppen
die so schwer erkrankt dass die
beratungspflicht ich werden ist deutlich
höher
und der anteil der menschen die an
dieser krankheit sterben in den
risikogruppen ist deutlich höher
ich glaube es gibt nichts was ist klar
dass wir hier eine größere problematik
haben wir haben auch in unsere
risikoeinschätzung darüber habe ich auch
letztens berichtet wir analysieren ja
viele systeme wir haben vier systeme in
deutschland mit denen wir den krankheits
schwere und grad die sogenannte berg
noch dieses berechnen und wir wissen
dass insgesamt diese krankheit auch nach
unseren analysen einfach eine schwere
krankheit last macht und einfach viel
mehr menschen infiziert werden und viel
mehr menschen in die notaufnahmen kommen
werden und viel mehr menschen beatmet
werden müssen und deshalb müssen wir
befürchten dass die arbeitsplätze nicht
reichen
diese krankheit ist schwerer und wird
mehr menschen betreffen wenn das immer
noch menschen im land gibt die das nicht
glauben
oder die mir nicht glauben oder die das
für panikmache halten dann kann ich nur
noch meinem wissen nach bestem wissen
und gewissen meiner kenntnis kann ich
sie nur auffordern endlich die augen zu
öffnen vor dieser real
wir müssen ich sage es nochmal wenn wir
uns alle daran halten das was vorgegeben
wird dann können wir diesen ausbruch der
epidemie maximal verlangsamt
und es mag sein dass es bestimmte
regionen gibt in denen bestimmte
zustände sind wo man noch weiter denken
kann ich sage es nochmal das liegt ja in
dem ermessen der entscheidungsträger vor
ort
wir müssen das analysieren wir tun das
so gut wir können wir haben viele
informationen um zu wissen wie in
bestimmten regionen deutschlands
bestimmte verbreitungswege sind und das
müssen leute entscheiden die unsere
daten entsprechend kennen situation in
den krankenhäusern sie haben wenn ich
sie richtig verstanden habe gerade
gesagt dass relativ oder des patienten
in krankenhäusern gibt die lediglich
husten als symptom haben habe ich das
richtig verstanden und wäre das ab wann
ist es empfehlenswert den weg zum
krankenhaus zu gehen und nicht zu hause
zu bleiben
spätestens wenn sie atemnot bekommen
atemnot bekommen das heißt also wenn sie
merken dass sie die die dass sie
wirklich schlecht luft bekommen dann
spätestens ist natürlich der zeitpunkt
gekommen wo sie sich an einen arzt
wenden bzw auch notfalls ins krankenhaus
eingeliefert werden
ich glaube nicht dass ich gehe nicht
davon aus dass menschen im krankenhaus
sind weil sie husten
der der kollege der kollege war vor
entschuldigung entschuldigung
entschuldigung der kollege ich weiß ich
weiß wir versuchen alle der reihe nach
dran zu nehmen und bitte alle halten
sich daran dass wenn man heute nicht
alle dran kommen können nein tue ich
nicht ich ignoriere den herren hier
vorne in ihn also eins nach dem anderen
ich bitte um verständnis ich merke
gerade dass die zuschauer die fragen ja
gar nicht mehr mitbekommen
sie haben alle kein mikro in der hand
also es geht um die daten der telekom
ich kann hier noch keine auswertung dazu
geben aber ich möchte noch mal folgendes
sagen die sind aggregierten daten keine
person persönlichen daten anonymisiert
und aggregierte daten sie uns einfach
zeigen ob die bewegungs ob die menschen
in deutschland sich wirklich weniger
bewegen um abschätzen zu können wie die
maßnahmen die geforderten auch umgesetzt
zu werden und dann können wir sehen
inwiefern das dann auch mit einer der
erwünschten rückgang der infektionen
koalieren so wird sagen drei fragen
schaffe man noch ganz schnell geht
zunächst die sie hat sich auch schon
länger gemeldet mich interessiert vor
allen dingen nehmen wir mal an die das
ist jetzt so hoffen die fallzahlen
werden gebremst
die massnahmen abstand halten etc haben
erfolg aber heißt das nicht dass diese
dann sehr lange in kraft bleiben müssen
weil man die wieder lockert wenn ich
zeige ja sofort wieder hoch gehen
wir müssen das immer beobachten und wir
müssen die maßnahmen entsprechend
anpassen das ist keine frage wir werden
jetzt erst mal schauen vielleicht die
nächsten zwei wochen werden wir sehen
wie sich das entwickelt und ich könnte
man sagen ist eine dynamische situation
wo man regelmäßig immer angepasst
reagieren muss aber niemand weiß wie
sich das entwickelt darum analysieren
was so gut was können und daran wenn
dann die massnahmen angepasst
aber jetzt sich gestern für eine herten
immunität ziel ausgesprochen obwohl die
bhu ganz klar sagt das ist das riskant
ist auch bei voller das möchte machen
möchte was sagen sie dazu
und die verhältnismäßigkeit der
geschäftsschließungen sind
hunderttausende unternehmer
wahrscheinlich vor dem ruin
die lehrerin einen masten schlicht in
der öffentlichkeit anzuordnen
die tschechen das getan und wie herr
polier das für die supermärkte weiter
erzählt wie er fast so jener liga
mitarbeiter ihren erst wieder seit
wochen empfiehlt die deutsche
gesellschaft für krankenhaushygiene sagt
auch jedem ast ist besser als keine also
ich sage es nochmal wir werden
wir werden hinterher wissen was die
besten maßnahmen waren die maßnahmen die
wir empfehlen sind nach bestem wissen
und gewissen gemacht die die idee einer
herdenimmunität halten wir für sehr sehr
schwierig weil dieses virus sich sehr
leicht überträgt und wir müssen alles
dafür tun dass wir die krankheitsfälle
so stark wie möglich reduzieren
wir wissen nach dem heutigen stand das
machst eintragen
vor allen dingen die anderen schützt
also die menschen die selber infiziert
sind
das wissen wir das sagen wir auch schon
seit langer zeit die menschen die selber
infiziert sind schützen andere vor der
infektion und das ist auch wichtig dass
diese menschenmassen kann für die im
gesundheitssystem das muss uns auch
allen klar sein
diejenigen die im krankenhaus arbeiten
und die in den pflegediensten und warm
aber das sind natürlich die menschen die
wir am meisten schützen müssen weil sie
natürlich mit infizierten das größte
risiko haben mit infizierten menschen
zusammenzukommen und wir lernen alle in
dieser krise wir tauschen uns ständig
aus und wir hoffen dass wir die besten
rezepte haben
dass wenn wir im nachhinein sehen letzte
frage sie tut mir leid für alle anderen
also die damalige grippe war eine sehr
schwere grippe und damals war das
gesundheitssystem schon sehr sehr sehr
gestresst also damals schon waren in den
krankenhäusern die intensivbetten sehr
stark besetzt und das dass das system
war sicher damals schon gestresst
das haben wir auch sehr viele
wahrgenommen also auch während der zeit
darauf da wurde sehr viel darüber
berichtet und das ist ganz klar
keine frage dass wir uns vor grippe
besser schützen sollten aber ich möchte
es noch mal klar sagen wir haben einen
impfstoff
also warum lassen sich die menschen in
deutschland die risikogruppen den wir
das jedes jahr empfehlen warum lassen
sich in deutschland nur 30 prozent der
über 60-jährigen impfen das ist eher ein
entscheidender unterschied wir haben
eher werkzeuge das ist ja auch ein punkt
den wir immer wieder betont
was ist sind die drei großen oder die
vier großen unterschiede zwischen grippe
und dem saas corona virus zur ersten
grippe gibt es einen impfstoff der allen
risikogruppen kostenfrei zur verfügung
gestellt werden bei saas corona gibt es
momentan keinen impfstoff grippe gibt es
medikamente wie ebenfalls verschrieben
werden können und dem frühen zeit meiner
krankheit helfen
aktuell stand heute gibt es gegen lars
corona wie o2 keine medikamente
drittens
kinder spielen bei influenza bei der
übertragen von influenza eine große
rolle bei saas krone ist es so dass nach
heutigem stand des wissens alle
altersgruppen die infiziert werden ein
gleiches risiko für andere darstellen
sie anzustecken und der fürchte
unterschied und den hatte ich gerade
noch mal erläutert die krankheitslast
ist deutlich größer das heißt die anzahl
der menschen die schwer krank werden in
risiko ist deutlich größer die
ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit die
übertragbarkeit ist ist ist höher und
die anzahl derjenigen die eine krankheit
verstorben ist höher wir haben also eine
ganz andere dimension
ja das sind ganz entscheidende
unterschiede und auch ich wäre froh wenn
die menschen sich einfach mehr gegen
grippe schützen würden und auch da
natürlich darauf achten dass sie andere
mitmenschen nicht anstecken das gilt für
jeden das sagen wir auch jedes jahr und
das werden wir auch im nächsten jahr
sagen und wir werden jedes jahr wieder
alle menschen auffordern sich impfen zu
lassen und ich hoffe dass wir dann
irgendwann im jahr 20 21 möglichst früh
einen impfstoff haben und dass ich dann
auch die menschen auffordern kann und
wir alle dass ich gegen korona impfen
lassen können wir hatten bislang die
situation einer epidemie diesen ausmaßes
in deutschland noch nicht
um es klar zu sagen eine derartige
epidemie von der haben wir immer in
vorhersagen haben wir immer gesagt dass
so was mal geschehen kann ja jeder
wissenschaftler der sich mit
infektionsmedizin wird fast weiß dass
die die schlimmste vorstände wir haben
eine pandemie ist mit einem virus das
über atemwegs über tröpfchen übertragen
wird und viele lungenentzündung
hervorrufen
das ist jetzt eingetreten das ist aber
eine andere situation als bei der grippe
unsere vorstellung die höchste
wahrscheinlichkeit war immer dass es ein
grippevirus ist ein mutiertes krippe wir
sein verändertes das dazu führt jetzt
ist ein corona virus aber die auswirken
sind dieselben wie gesagt dieses jahres
ist besonders
man hat besonders krankmachende
eigenschaften danke vielen dank und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]